allora dovremmo essere in diretta
vediamo un attimo se incominciano ad
arrivare di commenti nella chat dovremmo
essere in diretta
datemi un segno il segno che già stato
dato dalla regia curata dal meraviglioso
giovanni santonocito ragazzi benvenuti
all'appuntamento di giugno anche se
siamo a luglio della setta dei libri
quella che è stata la lettura di giugno
ossia l'uomo che scambiò rosso moglie
per un cappello per poter portare avanti
questa diretta come sempre però ho
bisogno del co fondatore della setta di
libri che oltre a in realtà no che in
questo momento si sta appoggiando online
per via di tutte le sono le misure di
sicurezza per del copit in realtà è una
un account
una pagina su su instagram che potete
trovare dicevo voglio presentare il gran
sacerdote marco cioni mio compagno
d'avventura per quale lo ribadisco
sempre persona senza la quale la 7 libri
non esisterebbe proprio senso
complimenti
grazie mille all'ora marco questo qui il
libro che hai proposto tour ufficiale
che scrive sea combatteva contro quello
che non finisce tore del premio strega
personalmente dentro che è solamente
vinto il premio strega vorrei dire così
noi non ci pieghiamo alle politiche dei
premi
va bene che diamo invece abbiamo deciso
di lento non abbiamo deciso la setta ha
deciso con la maggioranza
oliver sacks l'uomo che scambiò sua
moglie per un cappello sto parlando di
un neuropsicologo esempio un'eruzione di
prologo
cos'è che ti ha colpito di questo libro
prima di aprire tutta quanta questa
parentesi modo da far capire di che
stiamo parlando anche chi non ci segue
allora tendenzialmente sarò sincero la
prima se mi ha colpito il titolo non
sapevo il ticino non ha colpiti
va bene il senso ragazzi la copertina è
edito di contano altrimenti reggeremo
tutti quanti i libri con copertina e
bianche che si chiama libro 1 libro ii
libro tre quindi insomma questa roba è
importante poi mi ha colpito anche
leggendo la storia
il fatto che ci fosse un neurologo che
si era messo a scrivere un libro che
aveva l'impostazione di sì ha ragione
francesca la realtà no io sono molto
contento di averlo letto però so che la
setta è contro di me oggi è no mi ha
colpito il fatto che ci fosse un
neurologo che capisce l'importanza delle
storie non soltanto dal punto di vista
narrativo ma anche medico livello medico
capisce tantissimo a livello di
scrittura un po meno o neurologo questo
va detto longo infatti un addio oggi è
una giornata meravigliosa allora ragazzi
ragazzi noi quello che facciamo sempre
ovviamente non portare avanti una una
chiacchiera 2 e quindi giovanni come
vedete prenderei vostri commenti li
metterà in sovrimpressione in modo da
permetterci anche di leggi per lì
noi comunque stiamo con con gli occhi
sulla sulla chat quindi sentitevi liberi
di poter parlare noi durante la la
quando lo facciamo live
speriamo sempre anziché il pubblico in
tavoli nella discussione ma ci siamo
detti comunque sin dall'inizio che
avremmo avuto bisogno di portavoci di
vuoi un attimo diciamo presentare to
pian piano ha spiegato così proprio
allora abbiamo cecilia l'ha detta bianca
che oggi alloggi insieme a me deve
portare avanti un compito arduo ma so
che è molto preparata per adesso bianca
intendiamo cadetta bianche intendiamo
con colei che rappresenta tutta la
parte della setta che ha amato questo
libro e che quindi lo consiglierebbe
l'ho apprezzato mi piace
intanto distruggere casa sua fuori
bavaglio che fate proprio fare un'opera
io mi rifaccio abbiamo roberta che se
non erro rebbe essere grigia esatto
e poi guglielmo grigio che vuol dire
tutti coloro che hanno letto il libro e
sono a metà tra l'amore e l'odio o che
magari si ritrovano proprio non aver
provato nulla e poi guglielmi ha messo
la posizione molto difficile annalisa sì
perché ragazzi ho letto una marea di
mail che per scegliere gli addetti ci
sarebbero stati oggi vi dò a tutti i
nomi in testa
annalisa del pan era che rappresenta
sempre più tardi la maggioranza della
setta a questo punto ho visto il
riscontro che abbiamo avuto su su
instagram e francesco commenta dicendo
che il libro è un ottimo sonnifero
magari ha scritto per rilassare i suoi
pazienti se questo libro e se la
demografica diciamo del del gusto di
questo libro fosse un quadro dove il
nero rappresenta il disgusto il bianco
quello che piace questo sarebbe nemmeno
secondo me il risultato questo è il
risultato visto così però ci sono degli
spazietti bianchi se si si si ascolta
che lancia e che mi cacciano
qualcun'altro esclusive che forse così è
meglio ragazze partendo dal bianco e poi
andando verso il nero per scala di grigi
presentate da dove chiamate da dove
chiamate dove siete presentati cosa fate
di dateci un po diteci un po di voi e
parti gli occhi e mi chiamo ceciliano di
roma e
parla subito del libro potete da quanto
tempo il primo libro che leggerò già lo
so io ero presente a tutti gli incontri
dal vivo che abbiamo fatto a roma e ho
letto quasi tutti i libri aparte 1 il
triora dell'albero di arance date le
considero un altro per non leggere
no perché non cavoli miei perché non
hanno i fantasy ha avuto tantissime
altre cose da leggere e quindi non per
lo studio quindi non potevo e e niente
questa esperienza mi è piaciuta
tantissimo fin dall'inizio anche perché
abbiamo fatto tantissima amicizie che
ancora durano negli eventi live abbiamo
fatto gli amici in sei ancora durano e
quindi io ho provato a partecipare
sempre tutte le volte e questo è stato
uno dei libri uno dei due libri che
sicuramente mi è piaciuto che
consiglierei veramente l'altro e profumo
che so che in molti casi nel mondo un
pianto è vero perfetto ci trovi molto in
là con guglielmo passiamo alla marcia si
allora ciao io sono roberta vengo da un
paesino vicino caserta ma vivo a
bruxelles
e adesso sto chiamando da formia dove
caserta casa statura è né paese
[Musica]
lo conosciamo è perfetto e quindi ma ma
io sono grigia proprio perché ho
interpretato il diritto molto alla marco
che come leggere un bugiardino di un
medicinale praticamente perché
normalmente quando le big giardini 70
per cento li capisco
e quello che capisco mi crea ansia e
sono state buone sensazioni che ho avuto
con questo libro
quindi a parte l'ultima ultimo step che
secondo me è stato il più bello è un
racconto come passaggio e media che ti
fa un po viaggiare ti fa andare il
cervello del paziente
secondo me ci sono troppi troppi termini
fini c è veramente rappresentano
vi era assurda per chi non è del campo
vabbè roberto aspetta che già ti sento
bella dormita facciamo presentare
analisi e poi andiamo direttamente a
scannarci tutti gli incontri la setta
anche voi dal vivo e ho letto tutti i
libri ovviamente tranne quello che è
profumo la sola cambiata letto tre
pagine è chiuso e sono nero abbiamo
proprio ying e lo yang e cecilia e anna
linea la stata annalisa tu sei stata
nera su profumo si è mai stata bianca su
qualche libro giusto per capire allora
sul centinaio tra grigio e anche
superato tutti i clienti donne profumo
che fa vennero è questo il padre nera
appunti o libro che ti piace giusto per
entrare nel tuo mood tragica fine
diretta su 20 ok va bene va bene ti
faccia cadere comunque dentro per
cattivello
no scherzo scherzo fanno cagare ibekwe
che proponiamo noi questa è la diversa
leggevo comunque un commento prima di
iniziare questa diretta di una ragazza
che è un ragazzo era si dice per etica
quindi una ragazza che non ha finito il
libro
ora io sono io sono per l'onestà ragazzi
esatto lori to die io sono per l'onestà
mi sono fermato qui se veramente pessimo
bene cosa succede a un movimento
religioso quando il gran sacerdote si è
auto scomunica si può fare ai tipo tipo
ratzinger e yumiko lato e tutti come
bergoglio come nei papa emerito quindi
e tu sei papà francesco
come si fa a non finirlo ti stimola
praticamente tu arrivi al secondo
capitolo lo finisci lo chiudi lo ripone
nel tuo cassetto e dc domani lo leggo
domani lo leggono l'ecofin che non
arriva il giorno della della diretta
più o meno come si è fatto quindi chiedo
perdono a nostra discolpa devo dire che
questo mese che è passato per me e
guglielmo è stata una follia ragazzi
proprio tra impegni lavorativi e altre
cose personali siamo stati veramente
pienissimi quindi poi se non vi siamo
stati neanche troppo dietro c
ci dispiace questa sta un po mi sentivo
di dover fare questa premessa si devo
anche ammettere per un'altra cosa io
l'ho trovato veramente illeggibile cioè
nel senso io riesco a leggere tutto ma
mi hanno rubato ammorbava ma aspettate
io ho letto pure questi due mattoni cioè
non so come dirty questi due mattoni che
sono loster la stessa struttura cioè a
volte sono casi e tutto quanto questi
l'hanno insegnato qualcosa questo da
subito mi stava molto male ho sbagliato
e sicuramente lo recupererò anche solo
per leggere l'ultimo capitolo che piace
tanto vai partiamo con la domanda di
rito
direi tipo cecilia partiamo dal nero dal
bianco io diventate vetere federica che
ci scriva mi è piaciuto davvero tanto
pur non essendo un romanzo sarà che si
studia medicina mi è piaciuto in
particolare lo stupore e rispetto allo
scrittore di fronte a persone così
diversa è questo quanto impartire se la
cosa pi
la maggior parte delle persone la odiato
se quindi partiamo dal nero perché è più
interessante arrivare al bianco e
diciamo fare quello che facciamo senza
dentro al contrario vai annalisa io
premetto che ha degli appunti scritti se
non mi scordo quello che devo dire
quindi tanto se leggo perché controllo
alla parto col dire che tu fai termini
troppo diciamo complessi e non spiegati
fino in fondo che comunque hanno
bloccato o rallentato la lettura io sono
come guglielmo del libro e lo avrei
chiuso al terzo capitolo quello che ho
passato momenti in cui lo leggevo per la
voglia di leggerlo nel senso per
sbrigarmi a finirlo dire cha settimana
libera per la gioiello che mi pare
e settimane ha detto no non mi va di
leggere leggo tra due giorni infatti
sono anche rimasto indietro con gli
stessa cosa ma successo lo ha messo
questo è stato così
mentre leggevo non ho capito la meta del
libro cioè ogni libro alla fine c'è una
fine un po stretto ma in cui lui liquido
un po le cose però alla fine del libro
il nostro vado veramente il fine dello
scrittore è stato un saggio e mi aspetto
che fu a fine libro mi dici quello che
alla fine vuoi trasmettere però essendo
ora comunque diciamo un romanzo otro
troppi dettagli troppe cose che comunque
deviavano da quello che era il numero
centrale del libro e poi sono altre cose
in quel etico più tardi però vado un po
io voglio aggiungere un commento su
questa cosa
segno che è stato anche un altro mio
grandissimo problema col libro cioè
questo qui si doveva chiamare storia del
cos'è agnosia con me qualche la
definiscono oppure racconti diagnosi se
tu mi nero chi come titolo il la prima
la prima cosa che leggo mi stai per
colando specialmente nel momento in cui
non è un romanzo dove il titolo è
l'ultima frase che racchiude tutto
quanto ma è quasi più simile a un saggio
quindi l'uomo che scambiò voglio per un
cappello mi fa pensare a un altro tipo
di libro è un saggio in realtà poi mi
sono sentito preso per il sud solo è
anche grande pietro citati
quello che sta in quarta di copertina
diciamo cioè io leggendo questa roba qui
quello che ho detto nelle prime storie
fatte che mi ha un po tratto in inganno
perché io mi aspettavo una roba comunque
molto romanzata molto narrativa e invece
è poi così non è stato poi per non vuol
dire niente ed è un saggio e quindi poi
è bello come saggio però insomma
l'aspettativa mi aveva portato un po
fuori anche a me all'inizio roberto
esilio tra l'altro sul titolo avevo modo
i miei appunti e problemi a me è
sembrato che lui non sapeva come
chiamare il titolo come chiamare il
libro è ammesso come titolo il primo il
primo caso che gli è capitato diretta
della vista recesso ci scrive guglielmo
penso che il titolo sia dato dalla prima
storia perché anche sax ha sofferto di
broso magnini ossia non lo sapremo mai
credo che sia un dato di fatto fidatevi
che per un medico studente questo saggio
è molto romano usato scusa roberta non
ti volevo fermare anzi no quindi ho già
un po l'ho già detto un po all'inizio
che veramente per me il problema
principale è stato è stata questa
lettura bloccata da questo costante
dalla costante ricerca di termini troppo
p 15 e per questo molto spesso capitava
che alla fine degli stessi io non
ricordavo i casi che avevo letto perché
non mi rimanevano impressi e non mi
davano tra l'altro emozioni proprio
perché lui secondo me li descriveva
molto da un punto ci sta appunto clinico
e senza focalizzarsi molto sulla persona
e invece non sono ne erano sono grigia
perché invece ci sono stati dei dei casi
verso la fine cioè che appunto la
seconda parte del libro come passaggio
in india ma anche tutta l'ultima parte
sul mondo dei suoi impicci che secondo
me sono state anche quei discorsi
filosofici si era detto nei vari step
del libro
che fanno un po riflettere sulla società
e ti fanno che arrivano diciamo qualcosa
però si cioè io mi tengo grigia perché i
casi interessanti ma veramente una
barriera perfette
non vogliamo andare avanti ma ceci
lealtà il tuo momento
aggiungo un'altra cosa su questa cosa
canto roberta e anche capitoli che se
come potevano essere molto più brevi ok
scambiato a mogli più capelli maestro ok
non hai capito c'è nel senso molto
subiti vabbè vabbè bozza d'accordo su
questa suns che mi sono stati troppo
poco approfonditi era cosa mi ha fatto
rosicare di più del tutto ma ne parliamo
dopo mai ceci allora io la prima cosa
che volevo rispondere al fatto proprio
dei termini tecnici che sono stati una
barriera per molti però io penso che
nonostante questo libro si è
estremamente divulgativo nel senso che
non sapevo niente di neuropsicologia ho
capito ho capito quello che lo scrittore
voleva dire e penso che se avessero se
avessero escluso anche quei pochi
termini tecnici che pure a me hanno dato
patito in un certo senso sarebbe stata
sarebbe risultato è una favoletta nel
senso come scriveva prima la cera il
commento di una studiata in effetti però
per essere credibile come scienziato
devi metterci un minimo
medicine delusi perché altrimenti perde
credibilità poi si si si legge i post
scriptum sono anche perché penso che
questi casi diano stati pubblica
singolarmente almeno da quello che si
capisce e i sono arrivate anche risposte
da scienziati e quindi in un certo senso
era cioè deve comunque essere credibile
scientificamente il libro poi la parte
emotiva invece a me ha colpito
tantissimo io non come ho detto non
capisco assolutamente ingenti di
neuropsicologia infatti mi sarebbe
piaciuto è stato qualcuno che se ne
intendeva però come lui tratta il
paziente come intanto come lui cerca
sempre di capire come descritto il modo
in cui cerca di capire cosa c'è oltre
alla malattia del paziente cosa c'è
nella persona cioè secondo me è una cosa
molto importante che apre molti cioè lo
è lo consiglierei proprio per questo
perché ci dobbiamo sempre ricordare che
anche la malattia più più terribile più
non lo so che sembra limitante che quasi
sembra una persona non sia tale in
realtà dietro sempre un'anima non so una
persona una persona vera che ha bisogno
di affetto ha bisogno di essere
potenziata nelle sue capacità e poi
tantissime inquietudine proprio emotiva
perché pensi che quelle cose potrebbero
capitare effettivamente e ti chiedi
veramente dove sta il limite tra tra
cosa ci caratterizza come essere umano
cioè la parte la riflessione filosofica
molte sue tante mi è piaciuta anche di
poter applicare dei concetti che tu
potresti ipotizzare così tipo ma pensate
mi dimentico tutto da fino a quando ero
piccola e non mi ricordo più niente e
invece indiani a sapere che esistono
veramente queste situazioni in di
veramente importante
agli agenti e allora margot secondo la
tua posizione perché poi in realtà sono
assolutamente cavalcare di anticipato il
commento di carmen
sabato si è sempre anche a me tranquilla
era ovvio che avremmo parlato di casa
era solamente un atto per fare un
capello
l'ultimo sul generico ecco io sono
bianco bianco diciamo come ho detto
secondo me
l'impatto iniziale è stato un po
soffocante relazione al fatto che mi
aspettavo qualcosa di diverso
e a me ha colpito in maniera molto forte
anche perché secondo me io forse ma
secondo me anche in generale in italia
non abbiamo questa grande non ci
insegnano a considerare le malattie
psichiche come vere e proprie malattie
cioè se vedi uno che c'è una stampella
lo capisci che ammalato se invece di una
persona magari c'è un problema
psicologico quindi non è immediatamente
percepibile così all'occhio un po più
fatica almeno questa è la mia esperienza
e quindi sicuramente dal punto di vista
mi ha colpito dal punto di vista dei
casi secondo me la seconda parte è
quella più più interessante perché la
parte delle malattie come superpoteri
che è un po questo il concetto diciamo
del terzo step è stata veramente ficca
il caso del tour etico che riusciva a
suonare la batteria nel jazz solo perché
era tour etico nel momento in cui ha
smesso di esserlo ha perso questo sua
scintilla diciamo mia è un concetto figo
che è quasi cioè sembra quasi una
metafora scritta per colpire non un caso
reale però invece è fico che se esista
proprio nella nella realtà è quello dei
semplici e soprattutto dei fratelli
calcolatori è stato molto interessante
nel vedere come poi quando li hanno
separati hanno perso un po la loro la
loro peculiarità in generale mi è
piaciuto molto l'approccio alla malattia
come non solo un'anomalia da correggere
ma anche con una peculiarità di una
persona che magari è quella persona
proprio perché a quella malattia
ovviamente nei limiti della possibilità
di vivere una vita semi normale questa
cosa mi ha molto colpito e guglielmo
educatrici dell'introduzione del libro
no io posso fare per una volta da
moderatore cioè posso assolutamente
viaggiare all'interno di questa
discussione bene se alla fine questa
escursione avrò voglia di leggerlo e
finirlo o se invece che marra bene dove
sta parlando di casi state tutti quanti
più o meno sottolineando il fatto che ci
sia ce ne sia uno in particolare molto
bello questo viaggio in india se non so
se è d'accordo anche se non la nera
facciamo così dire ognuno è il caso che
vi ha colpito di più è così poi andiamo
a fare una via di me in analisi e fateci
sapere che in chat esami fasulli di fare
una mega ecco partiamo da da cecilia
andando verso il nero stavolta così me
lo sappiamo che il primo caso è stato
veramente apprezzando allora devo dire
viaggio in india forse quello che mi ha
colpito di meno anche se l'ho apprezzato
come un pregiudizio è stato non ricordo
il nome perché non ci sono troppi nomi
quello della della signora che riesce
che dopo tanti anni riesce a ricordare
le canzoni di che sentiva da bambina
quando era in ireland che aveva
completamente dimenticato a sentirle
proprio non avevamo
esatto però poi viene spiegato che li
sentiva forse perché hanno un grande
impatto emotivo su di lei
insomma viene lasciato un po aperto
questo questa discussione però cioè come
la sua malattia che poi dura poco perché
queste questa specie di che erano
attaccabile mi ricordo bene i termini
erano tipo ai tempi vale per cui anche
non so se lo sa lei sentiva le canzoni
nella testa non riusciva e non riuscivo
a togliersi le non capiva da dove cioè
non capire da dove venissero da dove
fossero uscite perché noi avevamo mai
sentite in questo modo lei recupera la
sua infanzia che aveva perduto
completamente cioè una cosa no stupendo
il senso perché pensi sia cioè sia un
sogno per una versione che la vive di
aver perso una parte della vita a
ritrovarla così per una malattia poi se
quello
sì diciamo che lei avevano si capisce
aveva delle reminiscenze di canzoni che
ha sentito quando era molto piccola in
in irlanda scozia non mi ricordo in
irlanda e lei diciamo ha perso fin da
subito il contatto con i genitori per
motivi di storia di vita e quindi non
aveva praticamente nessuna memoria della
sua infanzia proprio zero totale e
attivo 80 anni d improvviso comincia a
sentire queste canzoni ma sentire cech
che il libro racconta che lei si sveglia
pensaci la radio accesa proprio come se
fossero lì queste canzoni che però gli
riportano non solo la canzone in sè ma
anche alla memoria tutte le emozioni che
ha vissuto con la famiglia con i
genitori
insomma tutto questo no ma qui e ti
ripeto sembra scritto perché colpire
verde è successo a questa cosa folle
sembra un pochino sembra un po l'opposto
del racconto dell'uomo ma il marinaio
perduto quello che è stato all'inizio
cat errori che è terrorizzante per
quanto mi riguarda perchè l'idea di
perdere i miei ricordi equivale per me a
perdere me stesso tanto che tutte le
persone che ti dicono ma no io credo
nella reincarnazione una figata
gli dico che la ricreazione è un
concerto terrorizzante perché tanto se
non ricordi cosa hai fatto inutile è
come se morissi si riavvia assi se
vorremo mai sognato si dovrà solamente
un commento sui primi due capitoli
quindi mi sono sentito che in quelli
metterceli mezzi sono bravo vai roberta
parlaci del bugiardino della tachipirina
che ti ha colpito no allora battello in
india ma non ne mancano colpito sti ca
te che non mi hanno creato
esageratamente ansia diciamo che ci sono
riusciti a comprendere un po di più e
passaggio in india a me è piaciuto tanto
proprio perché pur essendo tumore
cerebrale maligno che provoca appunto
del monte laser comunque è stato bello
perché lui ha prescritto proprio
l'assenza secondo me dice e stato un po
gusto un po più sul paziente che
viaggiava in posti che forse lei non
aveva neanche visto quindi è stato
qui stanza è stata fissata diciamo dal
potere il macchinario della nostra mente
è invece al di là di questo mi è
piaciuto tanto anche l'artistico
autistico perché invece da questo cioè
dal punto di visto tutta questa parte
che descrive per chi non ha letto
appunto descrivere gli autistici ma
anche i disabili
a me è piaciuta perché comunque ci sono
dei modi per inserire queste persone
nella società e la società non fa niente
praticamente per pensarlo anche perché
per esempio l'artistico autistico lui
riusciva a produrre nel dettaglio
oggetti cose che vedeva signori tante e
quindi oliver sacks appunto lui
proponeva di inserirlo per fare i
disegni di determinati libri di botanica
quindi amia fattori a me è piaciuto
perché ha fatto riflettere
effettivamente sulla società di oggi che
non fa niente per queste persone quando
invece c'è la possibilità di aiutare in
qualche modo è però si altri non lo so
questo perché analista a darti una mano
sono quelli che non sai
allora io concordo perché anche il
mistico artistico l'autistico si è
quello artistico tutta autistico
un po perché vabbè consiglio un punto a
un futuro sempre la parte di psicologia
unità arte quindi anche un po per quello
ma anche se anch'io penso per queste
comunque sax cercò di inserire la città
anche con i suoi problemi ma ha dato uno
sguardo anche la sua interiorità nel
senso sia un problema di santa fè a un
problema anche questo ragazzo però con
la sua arte fantasia il suo modo di
esprimersi a una cultura calci lauro
qualcosa da cogliere
anche in in lui attraverso comunque
l'arte riesce a esprimere riesce a
essere anche lui a chi voleva diciamo
come gli altri anche diciamo non pensano
questo ok io dico quello che mi ha
colpito di più che per la realtà alla il
caso e ma colpi di più è stato quello
dell'amico di sax che si vive quelle due
tre settimane da cannes è praticamente e
non la vive da cane è una metafora per
dire che riceve un olfatto super
affinato e praticamente sveglia e a
questo il fatto super affinato che gli
permette di ricordarsi a memoria i
negozi delle strade di new york a roma
folle che ti ripeto io leggendo lì
pensavo queste robe
chissà se sono veramente successo stiamo
leggendo un libro di finzione e poi
l'ultima magia ci dirà chi ha tutto
inventato però no quindi però la cosa
che mi ha colpito di più è stata quella
dei gemelli in relazione al fatto che
loro quando un certo punto al sax cade
un barattolo con delle penne e loro
subito riescono a dire quante sono
quelle penne cioè tipo 370 penne dico
una cosa a un numero a caso e li usa per
il punto di questo libro è che secondo
me tu leggendo la persona normale tra
virgolette non malata non riesce mai a
capire fino in fondo quello che su
quello che viene descritto
invece in quel momento quando ha fatto
l'esempio che se tu vedi tre bicchieri
su un tavolo
cioè tu lo sai che soffre tu lo capisci
subito e sono tre non c'è bisogno di
metterti a contarli e lo stesso i
gemelli riuscivano a fare lo stesso però
con 72 penne 372 penne capito elimia
proprio colpito il fatto che c'è chi e
sono riuscito per la prima volta in
tutto il libro a entra nella mentalità
di ok come io vedo tre bicchieri su un
tavolo e subito so che sono tre loro
vedono un numero infinito di chicchi di
riso dentro un barattolo riescono a
capirlo ed è una roba che li proprio
gamma cioè è riuscita a farmi capire
quale mente che era una cosa che
riuscivano a fare solo insieme
no non riuscivano a farla
pendente mente però poi loro diciamo che
insieme si vedono questo linguaggio
matematico che solo tra di loro si
capivano è come se parlassero attraverso
i punti
[Musica]
c'è un aereo fortissimo c'è stata da noi
c'era prima il commento di mani
qualcuno vuole parlare di questo di
questo capitolo della questa donna cieca
dicevano spetta alessandro per scrive
anche mani mi ha colpito in modo
positivo una donna cieca che impara da
zero percepire se stessa e ad usare le
mani dopo anni e anni di vita sì quella
megera le è stato forse la parte di
marco interessato o meno quello degli
artigiani era quella di alti fantasma
giusto faceva parte di niente c'è tutta
una sezione del libro che è relativa
agli arti fantasma a perdita della
possibilità di percepire propri arti
anche gente si sveglia nel letto non
riconoscendo il suo piede come suo robe
folli però lì proprio non sono riuscite
a entrarci dentro perché non riesco a
capirlo
quindi a me ma un po spy nella foto
spaesato veramente quelli con i casi al
limite di quello che può capire un
essere umano ad esempio anche la tizia
che non sia più il suo corpo cioè non lo
non lo senti sa più come suo veramente
sempre a un racconto di fantascienza
sempre un racconto fantasy
invece questo ti succedono ma la stessa
cosa va beh ho ritrovato tantissime cose
del di libri che ha letto in passato
magari solo come che però erano solo
ipotizzate nel reale cioè esempio la
storia dell'amico dell'università di sax
che che sente tutti gli odori
alla fine perché se chi l'ha letto e
profumo praticamente infatti l'ho anche
scritto che riesce non sapevo che poteva
succedere davvero è davvero
impressionante
c'era un altro come luogo per me dice
cristiana scusa perché giovanni viene
ammessi vaglieri sorgendo al contrario
per me il fine ultimo di sax e quello di
far capire
che le partner orologi che non sono
reversibili
ma ciò che è stupefacente la plasticità
della persona e delle loro possibilità
di ripresa diverse qui veniamo secondo
me un po al problema che ho percepito
nel libro nel senso che da quello che io
mi aspettavo sempre quindi parla della
mia aspettativa cioè a me sembra
leggendo lo ma magari è stato lui che
non è stato proprio grande scrittore ma
più grande neurologo che questi lisi li
ha visti per un giorno
c'è tanto che lui ha ricevuto questi
questi pazienti a parte qualche caso di
pi gemelli in cui si capisce che lui ha
fatto questa visita
una volta nel suo ufficio ha scritto
quello che doveva scrivere e poi
arrivederci e grazie
ovviamente non è stato così però a me è
mancata un po dice di analisi e
avanzamento nel tempo del paziente
perché altrimenti mi sono ritrovato con
ok e quanti prime conoscenze
però poi non c'è mai stato un momento di
ok è passato un anno e si è sviluppata
così abbiamo successo questo siamo
andati in quella direzione
è sempre stato un primo impatto bravo
cioè quello che a me ha fatto proprio
abbandonare l'interesse e che non c'era
involuzione
ora per assurdo questo commento di
cristiana proprio quando parla di
plasticità della persona e possibilità
di ripresa diverse io mi son fermato
all'inizio ragazzi quindi sono il primo
ad ammetterlo non vedono non ho visto
plasticità cioè leggere che ne so
che cos'è l'interpretazione ai sogni
tutta una roba lì tu che cosa hai un
caso ti viene descritto esattamente cosa
ciò che lo stato un sogno c'è una
ricerca un andare a fondo e alla fine
interpretare questa cosa qui
eventualmente qualche volta anche
riuscire a far sciogliere dei nodi uno
su cui essendo completamente diverso
perché trattandosi comunque tutte queste
patologie
questi deficit che lui chiama
all'interno non mi rifaccio sarei loco
sinistro destro tutta questa roba qui
sembra più che altro del ho incontrato
questo progetto che non riusciva a
riconoscere gli oggetti
vabbè dai continui stonare ciao un po
che dico a cosa è servito anche quello
sappiamo che non è così no dico per la
chat nel senso è ovvio stanno nella sua
clinica quindi lo sappiamo che li ha
visti più volte gli accurati e ci ha
passato del tempo ma questo non esce
fuori da quello che lui ha scritto
spesso e questo un po il problema vedo
che annalisa fa sì con la testa
vai vai chiamato una raccolta di di
patologie così e mette lì a caso è lui
ritorno mi raccontava una ma non ho
trovato un evoluzione unici acuti e il
museo non trovando anche la questione
emotività del di fax né raccontarmi
almeno questi racconti dando trasmesso
nulla
fondamentalmente è un racconto di questi
modo rotte di questi pazienti che
avevano questi problemi messi l'indagine
il libro e raccontate per fare un
esempio assurda fili mi collego presso
un altro mese
ma ricevano quello è un diciamo che io
non ne capisco molto bene un po simile a
questo libro diciamo due cesti anello
esatto però lì la questione orientati
entrato nel tanto io l'ho preso a cuore
mi ha ispirato anche a leggere a capire
come potevo fare
pertanto anche mons tanta carne per
esempio no quindi l'emotività c'è stato
il messaggio è arrivato ma qui non c'è
nulla
potevo anche non leggerlo questi
piantati
alla clinica di casi missili ma
onestamente sì perché a me è sembrato
c'è proprio denunci per me ne doveva e
si doveva lavorare più su un
introduzione su una conclusione in modo
da creare proprio un filo linea noi non
c'è stato al di là di questo a dividere
il libro in quattro parti perdite
eccessi e quant'altro e poi secondo me
c'è il post scriptum si poteva usare
molto meglio nel senso che per me non
c'è stata neanche tantissima differenza
tra il post scrittum e la descrizione
del caso insieme che per me il post
scriptum doveva essere un affrontare il
caso da un punto di vista più clinico se
potevi avere delle informazioni in più e
invece è il caso nel capitolo principale
diciamo doveva essere forse raccontato
appunto più come come storia in modo un
po più narrativo per quanto sia un
saggio ma abbiamo visto appunto che con
fuer libro the con libro di maggio cioè
diciamo che lui invece si focalizza o
più sulla narrativa
quindi sì secondo me c'è stato proprio
lo so che abbiamo detto per cui non è
uno scrittore che il mio neurologo però
qualcuno arriva fratture né corretto
libro insomma che va bene anche anche
l'errore licia al alison che dice lui è
un neurologo e analizza patologia che
all'epoca erano sconosciute questo libro
si inserisce in un contesto storico
forse si può dire che invecchia male ma
dal punto di vista storico
l'analisi va fatta notte a ponte storico
credo fosse punto è ovvio ovvio che sarà
esaurito 80 foto scattate
almeno 70 70
comunque diciamo che è ovvio che che
libera stato pubblicato 35 anni fa però
poi uno c'è nel senso
secondo me questa cosa che va bene a
fare analisi storica soprattutto in
relazione fatto che un saggio però poi
noi oggi lo leggiamo e noi oggi diamo
interpretazioni in base a quello che
stiamo vivendo in questo momento quindi
non ti posso dare cioè non si può dare
una risposta come avrebbe potuto essere
concepito 35 anni fa io sto leggendo
adesso e quindi ci sta che adesso sia
invecchiato male quindi lo recepisca
male inizialmente perché poi secondo me
nè per me è stato tutto un problema di
aspettativa se mi avessero detto stai
per leggere un saggio di questo tipo è
invece che non ci fosse stato un
aspettativa di narrazione sarebbe stato
totalmente bianco è l'unico problema per
me è stato quello roma prima le cosa
scusa la crisi rende ugualmente nel
sanzione avrei letto per il titolo
perché io ho un problema con questo tipo
di g.col ieri mattina tantissimo e poi
soprattutto una volta che ho letto
questo titolo e vengo a sapere che una
storia vera cioè fatta mi hai comprato e
lo leggerò lo leggo comunque ripeto il
fatto che siano storie vere la cosa che
più mi continua a rimanervi nel cervello
con una roba folle
penso quindi penso che la fia sale riad
a leggerlo comunque viva e sta bene
la sua ragione del commento di roma 123
che dice ho letto tutti i libri di
oliver sacks un uomo e medico di una
sensibilità rara ebreo omosessuale
nato in una londra che li discrimina va
a livelli estremi c'è una cosa che sta
un po emergendo e che secondo me è un
attimo per aprire una parentesi un
pochino più ampia per poi tornare a
discutere del libro che questa sono
rimasto un attimo sconvolto quando ho
letto che era del 70 cioè credevo che
fosse molto molto molto più vecchio come
come libro e questa cosa mi fa capire
quanto siamo indietro ancora in quella
che è la percezione di tutta quella che
hellas diciamo sanità mentale delle
persone cioè negli anni 70 erano molto
avanti sotto determinati dal punto di
vista chirurgico e altre cose non mi
stupisce il fatto che ad oggi ancora un
qualcosa che magari non sia così
eclatante che ti faccia quindi subito
infilare all'interno della cartella è
pazzo ma quindi una depressione
[Musica]
altri piccoli diciamo tratti di problemi
di ciò che mi chiamo problemi anche se
non sono problemi ma di sinonimi di una
nonna di momenti che non è sanissima non
vengono riconosciuti ma ero a casa gli
uomini italiano chiusi tipo agli anni 80
nel 78 una cosa del genere se sei mesi
cioè noti ma capire quello che ci tour
nel senso che i manicomi erano il
simbolo del tutti quelli che sommati
indiscriminatamente qualunque tipo di
mad e pazzia che poi definirli matti e
già sbagliato
insomma per capirci li butto dentro lo
stesso lo stesso posto chiudere porta a
riderci grazie c'è questa era un po la
filosofia negli anni 80 in italia per
cui c'è esatto che è estremamente certe
e che mi fa anche fare un'analisi che
forse non è riuscito a spiegare
benissimo ma casi come questo
equivalgono per me sa se dovesse
trasformare il mentale in fisico
direi che sono casi di persone che
improvvisamente lì si amputa un braccio
io devo riattaccare e persone quindi che
hanno visto torneo di assistenza
ad oggi però se mi faccio un graffio che
richiede tutti io ho anche bisogno di
assistenza anche se non è un qualcosa di
estremamente mortale dal punto di vista
mentale un graffio alla mente noi non lo
riconosciamo e noi gli diamo lo stesso
valore che invece può avere un qualcosa
di fisico non a caso
ovviamente negli ultimi anni c'è stato
un enorme attenzione in quella che è la
che cos'è mentre day il giorno della
giornata della vita mentale salute
mentale non so come e che secondo me è
l'unica cosa che mi avrei preferito un
libro però ovviamente non è questo che
mi permettesse ancora il più di entrare
quella che è un qualcosa di più
quotidiano e di più vasto host ai tavoli
ragionate strumento di antonio
presentato in pieno le esercitato la
professione in un periodo in cui si
chiedeva la fantascienza la psiche
dell'uomo non devi ma toccata nel modus
operanti di un medico continua e quindi
secondo me avrei preferito un qualcosa
che mi portasse invece che in contesti
assurti in contesti molto più più mani
per rendere questo discorso ancora più
moderno visto che io sono stato il primo
per esempio di avere momenti in cui ero
leggermente depresso niente di grave
però forse una mano mi sarebbe servita
capirò se posso dire posso arrivare
magari cina
no mi avvertì non capisco neanche di
queste cose di questi ambiti terzi sono
da noi e neuroni non credo che sia
libero sulla psicologia ma sulla
neuropsicologia sud anni come dire
proprio fini sincini qui la depressione
non credo che ad esempio tutte le che
nei suoi disturbi d'ansia di depressione
non sono credo generati proprio qui sta
facendo un esempio per far capire il
concetto di che se tu oggi hai un graf
sete si tagli con coltelli e temete tre
punti è normale ti dimettere tre punti
se hai un leggero problema neurologico
che è meno diciamo visibile alle persone
quindi poi è
l'esempio vorrebbe essere atto gr
dislessia fino a dieci anni fa seri
dislessico eri solo uno che non andava
bene a scuola ma adesso per fortuna
hanno implementato e arrivano a capire
subito se a questo tipo di problema però
tante persone hanno passato anni di
inferno elementari e medie per che i
professori genitori non sa non capivano
quale fosse il loro problema perché vuoi
applicavano per da subito certo non sai
cosa il mio è un discorso cioè a me
piace sempre più delle volte riportare
specialmente sense aggio una chiacchiera
un qualcosa che possa essere una
discussione poi che veramente permette
alle persone di parlare dell'oggi e del
della crisi ecco perché ho detto che lui
e so che lui voleva parlare di eccessi e
sono d'accordo con antonio quando dice
oggi si sta iniziando a dare molto
valore del supporto psicologico
associato alla cura vera e propria di
una patologia icsa però mi interessa
proprio dire come ancora oggi la salute
mentale non viene tanto non se ne parla
tanto ed era mi ha calciato al fatto che
questo libro qui è uscito solamente 40
anni fa praticamente quindi mi stupiva
pensavo fosse molto prima e poi ti dico
io da un uomo di marketing penso anche
che se tu non scrivi un libro su cose
così estreme nessuno se lo legge nel
senso che è il punto forse anche quello
che siccome sta in un momento storico in
cui qualunque cosa può essere percepita
come che si sta inventando delle
fandonie se non scrivi di roba così
assurda la cosa che mi è piaciuta un
sacco è il fatto che facesse
continuamente riferimento altri iscritti
altre persone mi appropriato l'idea che
ci fosse comunque una comunità
scientifica che si muoveva in quel tempo
tutta quanta insieme verso una direzione
è però se non scrivi di questo tipo di
roba se non scrivi dei casi assurdi e
dei casi clinici eccezionali secondo me
non fai neanche colpo e poi non ci si
fida nessuno purtroppo napoli non era
che forse lui proprio non c'è proprio
come medico non si occupava di queste
cose quindi poteva certo poi
no non mi aspettavo che in un cuoco ma
giusta se una marmitta nostro dicendo
che mi sarebbe piaciuto ad oggi
affrontare un discorso molto più moderno
non sto dicendo che non era il libro di
cui volevo parlare solo questo però sarà
per esempio dice pensare ora c'è gente
c'è ancora c'è ancora gente che dice che
la repressione significa solo essere un
po tristi è una parentesi volessero
parentesi a per esempio scusa aspetta un
commento di marianna che dice
l'assistenza neurologica quella
neuropsichiatrica sono completamente
diversi il neurologo si occupa del
fisico lo psichiatra della psiche ok
però ad esempio se non è la cosa [ __ ]
cadere come lui approccia la neurologia
e proprio che dice sì ok noi ci
occupiamo del l'uomo come se fosse
potremmo approcciare la cosa come se
fosse un computer a quelle parti che gli
permettono con i processori di arrivare
a fare il calcolo esatto
e se non ci riesce di che c'è un
problema meccanico lui però approccia
anche dal punto di vista umano personale
e non è quello nel senso che secondo me
questa cosa qui della neurologia e
neuropsichiatria che sono componente
diverse di un approccio dicendo sì ma
vanno comunque unite per poi riuscire ad
averci una cura vera e propria perché se
con cui solo il computer ma poi lui è la
persona resta da sola senza nessuno che
l'aiuti è impossibilitato a vivere una
vita normale
a quanto pare il fisico ma non gli stai
dietro io ho infatti volevo dire che in
quel periodo ho scritto il libro fa
riferimenti a luglio che era un altro un
altro neurologo psicosi e infatti sono i
primi che si distinguono da loro
comunità che ha un approccio tecnologico
associo neuropsichiatrico nel senso nel
del primo capitolo il libro sacro una
metafora in cui dice che dove non arriva
alla neurologia possibile applicata
psicologia quindi questo tratto è
l'individuo quindi diciamo qualsiasi
individuo non solo come
come te stesso con un problema ma anche
con una personalità che va curata si
vede anche nel primo capitolo
quindi questa cosa insomma per lui è
veramente dice che devono andare a
braccetto le due cose che non possono
assolutamente essere separate si fa i
fatti
lui è un pioniere mai diceva lui infatti
è stato un pioniere di questa cosa che
ha preso queste due cose separate
dicendo ragazzi dobbiamo lavorare
insieme se no non ne usciamo
roma 120 notifica che c'è un film tratto
da uno degli iscritti di sax che si
chiama risvegli con robbie williams
pensate non avevo proprio idea forse
quindi adesso dovrò vedermela and bess e
per questo ci sta due palle così enormi
che dicevo ti arrampichi sugli specchi
davvero sta facendo vedere allora su cui
specchi mister anno indicando però va
bene si dicevano secondo me quello che
no scusate storia ho trovato molta
umanità in saks come come mesico c'è un
libro sulla stessa linea di uno
scrittore italiano e si chiama le libere
donne di magliano è molto scorrevole a
fronte dei casi più normali con
riflessioni sulla posizione sociale del
malato
immagino che mi prescrive secondo me è
uno dei messaggi più belli aspetta che
la ritrovano dei messaggi più belli e
che la tua anima e rimane in tavola
nonostante la malattia si risveglia con
stimoli profondi come l'arte la
religione molto commovente si sente
specola non sa più dissi ma insomma è in
giochini c'è rispetto a quello che
diceva prima gli fa eri fatto che non
c'è una morale un punto dove vuole
arrivare secondo me invece è molto
chiaro cioè proprio quello più ruoli è
il suo scopo principale a dire proprio
questo nel senso l'essere umano è
qualcosa che noi non capiamo al vino
del suo delle sue del suo cervello e
delle inquisito celebrali perché c'è
qualcosa di più ed è un punto molto
bella che va capito che va esplorato e
che non è banale
in questo momento di silenzio dopo nel
progetto quelle frasi profonde c'è
sempre un momento di silenzio ancora non
si sa cosa dire ma marco ti vedo pronto
io volevo solo dire che secondo me un
pericolo sono sto dicendo che sia
volontà di saks sto dicendo che un
pericolo che ho percepito quando uno
finisce agire questo libro e che
comunque poi ci sono comunque malattie
questo è quello che io ce n'è tanto
perché poi non dico che magari ci sia
questa veramente questo pericolo però io
ho percepito che alla fine tipo nel caso
della micro di sax che gli dava zucco la
droga pesante che non mi riguardano la
droga fosse e che si è svegliato il
l'olfatto di un cane li mezzo che
vogliate fatto venire un problema
neurologico vieni un po però poi come
dice lui
parlando dei gemelli loro vengono
separati cominciano a vivere una vita a
semi normale tra miliardi di virgolette
però poi alla fine la cosa veramente
ficazione che come professionista
neurologo ti trovi di fronte a una
scelta cioè dover privare la persona di
quello che le rende speciali quindi come
il tour etico che poi sapeva suonare la
batteria è però dargli una parvenza di
vita normale
oppure chi sono io per dire altri atti
cosiddetti di essere più etico perché
non è normale la malattia quindi poi non
sarai la batteria giusto per fatti un
mini spoiler v alla fine del tour etico
decide di di essere normale tutta la
settimana nato a nel weekend che non
prenderle medicina passano alla batteria
e secondo me hanno accertato sono rari i
casi in cui permette di farlo però
quando poi secondo me è la cosa più
più giusta da fare allora aspetta due
palle così dovevo rispondere scusatemi
continua non l'hai letto non sai nemmeno
che oliver sacks parla di
neuropsichiatria l'unica ragazza che ha
competenze di parlare e lei va bene
allora non lo so non so fatto sta che
che sia chiaro il fatto che io non abbia
finito il libro è il fatto che io lo
reputi ne cancella che lui che non ne
abbia preso non vuol dire che sto
dicendo che è una merda perché non l'ho
letto quando io ho parlato prima perché
questo ci tengo tantissimo ho detto
semplicemente non mi aspettavo che un
libro così sia stato scritto
recentemente perché perché per il
momento in cui l'ho scoperto ho capito
perché ancora siamo così indietro su
quelli che sono problemi molto più
piccoli rispetto a questi qui che sono
casi più grandi
avrei preferito per esempio poter
riuscire a parlare di casi più piccoli
che sono più moderni questa è
un'opinione che posso avere anche senza
avere l'esclusiva tecnologia non ero
psichiatria se proprio dobbiamo dirla
tutta però lei un lui e chi è che deve
parlare no secondo me abbiamo fatto
raggiungere qualcosa ragazza aveva
accusato che volete dire su questo libro
non so se contestualizzabile il fatto
che lui chiami i pazienti con semplice
nei confronti di martin cioè quando ti
piace a martini confronti di bach più
intellettuale oppure ritardati viola di
casi simili perché mentale ragazzi usate
le terminologie che però sono dell'epoca
in cui ha vissuto nel senso che
politically correct soprattutto
relazione alla medicina dell'epoca dove
ancora non era stato un po approvato
bollato edificio a tutte quante le
persone di questo mondo
altrimenti torniamo stiamo per entrare
nella polemica legata via col vento e le
foto dei chip ion max perché da
rappresenta una società razzista si è un
film del tempo in cui la società era
razzista poi è storia però può darsi
pure che lui cioè io in certi punti ho
interpretato per lui dopo i termini un
po in polemica anche perché poi cioè
penso che sia partito dal suo tipo di
ricerca islami non considerare più gli
autistici solo come degli idioti quindi
cioè lui credo sia uno dei passaggi
delle posizioni quindi mi chiamano
sempre che io li chiamo semplici però
poi il mostro che non è che non è vero
secondo me non c'è tanto di analizzare
in realtà è semplicemente che usava
terminologie erano di uso comune
all'epoca e purtroppo ci devi sta nel
senso che fai ma non ci puoi dare
indietro a dirgli non si dice idiota no
no no allora federico scrive definire
sax razzista no vi prego no nessuno
marco sta facendo una cosa diversa stai
dicendo che tutto il contrario sta
dicendo sta dicendo che magari se ci
sono delle terminologie un pochino forti
sono solamente legate a come si parlava
in quell'epoca e non ha fatto che lo
fosse e poi abbiamo erano 123 che io
avrei voluto avere online perché c'è le
sa tutte
non so se è una tipica o se veramente
una cultura tua complimenti comunque per
mettere un po di pepe al tutto sa cassa
è stato anche un folle provò di persona
varie droghe psichedeliche per
descriverne gli effetti e le visioni e
riportò tutto in allucinazioni che è
molto interessante un esperimento in
realtà da leggere
sicuramente si può dire che non era
proprio un medico classico e
tradizionalista
sicuramente ne sapeva di marketing
perché c'è il segnale perché tutte
queste sono delle idee comunque che un
minimo possono integrare un lettore che
non è semplicemente un appassionato di
c'è un'anima uno studente non lo mette
sempre dentro campo poi ci sta che vai
anche molto in là per capire quello che
insomma per provare cose che gli altri
non possono provare soprattutto secondo
me dal neurologo capire cosa prova 1
quando c'è un allucinazione visto che
poi a che fare con questo persone tutti
i giorni ti dà una marcia sicuramente in
più poi quando santi nel baratro non lo
sai mai quello che trovi
però ci si sa si vede che è uno che
insomma amava quello che faceva e andato
tutto se stesso per farlo tutti di dei
spie riprendiamoci l'ultimo quarto della
ragazza tolta avete altro da dire
secondo me abbiamo un po elettorato
tutto quanto in maniera abbastanza
approfondita per spiegare come funziona
luglio e agosto tanto padre morì
spiegarlo perché questa questo libro non
ha portato prima prima di chiudendo
leggere l'ultimo commento
intere con un commento sotto che viene
ignorato che diceva sia i termini video
per ritrovare se giovanni milano ma non
siete erano idiota che ed efficiente
vengono utilizzati in accezione mediche
come f affetti dagli ossia ed efficienza
quindi vedi uno dovrebbe un attimo
capire il mondo e il contesto per poter
effettivamente prima di poter criticare
qualcuno una volta io non è mica dissi
che era una cagna per intendere che la
scarsa recitare ma milano prostituta ed
esce in una sede
malissimo anche era una camera corinna
cioè la collina di boris kangra galli
anche in foto però diciamo sì che questa
cosa
comunque sì marco sono d'accordo con te
quest ultimo quarto dovevano occupare un
attimo per spiegare come vogliamo
muoverci durante l'estate schifo allora
sì a luglio che poi ha già cominciato
quindi la stiamo già siamo già dentro
siamo già dentro questo processo caso
abbiamo deciso abbia deciso che intanto
l'estate
della libertà quindi niente step niente
libro che va letto per forza in questo
mese in questi tempi perché viene tutto
io personalmente magari parla anche
guglielmo sentivamo necessità di
liberarci un po dagli schemi e di
leggersi un po quello che ci pareva in
giro tanto per restare per forza dietro
a studenti e calcolate che marco più di
tutti perché comunque continua a dirlo
certo c'è molto marcia c'è un po di
guglielmo nella scelta dei libri marco
mascis se ne smazza anche tanto e quindi
sono stato il primo a proporre questa
cosa qui anche per provare una cosa in
realtà volevo fare io da un bel po
c'è una realtà già il terzo me il terzo
mese avrebbe dovuto fare questa cosa noi
per due mesi vogliamo dare come dice
marco la libertà di leggere quello che
si vuole ma fare un gioco inverso cioè
se prima eravamo noi a dare la
possibilità di scegliere tra i due libri
adesso vogliamo che le persone scelgano
il libro che vogliono loro
però su un tema che viene dato pesa in
modo da trasformare e mantenere sempre
attiva la pagina di instagram
ma invece di avere ogni volta dei tanti
commenti di tanti commenti diversi sullo
stesso libro
noi vorremmo commenti sullo stesso tema
di tanti libri diversi e quindi possono
parlare di come vengono diciamo
analizzati questi concetti o come
tornare a scuola e fare la tesina per
certi versi solo che adesso sono vi darà
un v quindi fare maniera tranquilla la
cosa [ __ ] poi è che abbiamo creato un
file drive se andate su instagram nelle
storie di luglio lo trovate in cui tutti
gli addetti hanno potuto scrivere il
titolo del libro che hanno che
propongono perché l'hanno proposto e
hanno lasciato anche il profilo in starà
quindi se poi lo leggete scegliete leggi
equilibrio e potete farvi una
chiacchiera o chi lavora proposto potete
aggiungerlo parlarne tra o in questo
modo non c'è necessità di passare
attraverso sempre a solo terzo la setta
ma si crea un giro di addetti che tra di
loro geni si arricchiscono a vicenda e
capace pure che
è capace pure ed è una cosa che anche
spingono di fare se ne volete leggere di
più o se volete anche leggerne uno e
magari parlare di altri che avete già
letto tv possono un pochino tornare cioè
magari ora ancora vi diremo il tema
anche se l'avevo già comunicato però
giusto perché se l'è perso magari
iniziamo che diamo il 3
iniziamo qualcuno ha letto qualcosa che
vuole già commentare e quel messaggio
potrebbe stimolare un altro a leggere
quel quel libro in una sorta di catena e
di continuo ping pong in atto il tema è
diversità e diversità in tutte le
concezioni e possibili a diciamo
declinazioni quindi di eba la più
classica e brutto dirlo classi ma
diversità razziale
non lo so identità sessuale ecc poiché
ma dono di dio su questo disco no no no
dice di tutto perfettamente tranquillo
però siamo stati molto toccati da da
quello che è successo quindi con blm è
stato dimesso del pride ma ce lo siamo
detti ma perché non facciamo diversità e
questa voglia dire non diversità che
palle perché sembra che puoi cavalcare
per forza il momento in cui tutti quanti
si svegliano vendevano e devono per
forza fare diversità no noi vogliamo
veramente fare secondo me e sotto questo
punto di vista una scelta ampissima
proprio perché è interessante vedere
come ognuno di voi tira fuori questo
tema non deve essere un libro su su sui
neri non dev'essere un libro sugli a
prego doveva essere un libro sul piano
dovrà essere uscito se transessuali può
essere un dio molto probabilmente
leggerò colibrì molto probabilmente
leggero colibrì perché mi piace
tantissimo l'idea di dell'immagine di
quest'uomo che si muove si muove si
muove per non fare niente quest'uomo che
sta da solo nella sua vita si sente
l'unico a fare questa cosa ma poi nella
sua unicità è molto più simile a tutti
noi non lo so colore rosa ragazzi
diversità come vi pare io leggerò il
buio terrasini
ad esempio all'inizio che quindi è il
falso il libro più classico può avere in
mente relazione a questo tema ma perché
ne andava di leggerlo quindi come vi
pare non c'è miti ragazze voi avete già
scelto il libro che sta già avvenendo in
mente qualcosa ok roberta no annalisa tu
che cosa io prendo di pasolini che ai
ragazzi di vita e poi quelle dinosauri
ok per essa è e cosa il secondo non lo
conosco di che parlasse colella casolini
questo ragazzo era un fratello che è
disabile a tendoni di dow e inter mette
lo diciamo lo nasconde perché si
vergognava di lui ma poi in vivamente
supereroe il suo miglior amico quindi
molto caldo il wonder italiano diciamo
perché la sicilia
allora io di libri che ho già letto
minuto avvenuto in mente tantissimi da
continuare quindi con the game pad eroe
di instagram hai mai è però ancora da
leggere non lo so sicuramente come
leggere anche i ragazzi vita veramente
però se posso dire una cosa consiglio a
tutti i seggi
adesso proprio alla fine di questo libro
c'è di l'uomo che scambia suo meglio per
un cappello viene citato finzioni di
borges che è un libro che parla viene
citato in relazione il caso dei due
gemelli
iniziano sempre racconti di persone
particolari che sembra quasi esattamente
la trasposizione fantasy di quello che
potrebbe essere libro che abbiamo appena
eletto quindi della serie lo consiglio
perché altri mini mi sa che non l'hanno
più con i primi sono già sterminare
questi titoli come a quest'ultima di
poker funzioni finzioni hanno capito
minzioni
ok e quindi niente ragazzi c'è libertà
totale poi per agosto vedremo a
settembre
state calmi tranquilli perché oggi ho
visto che la gente si agitava
riprenderemo con lo stile classico si
l'ordine anche nella zona molto c'è
ordine quadrati tranquilli step si va
avanti a settembre ma è lui la nostra
estate libertà via e speriamo speriamo
di poter tornare live
ma la cosa che abbiamo imparato da
questa quarantena e che dobbiamo
riuscire però a rendere tutto quello che
invece è virtuale quindi noi abbiamo
sempre e questo perché ci siamo fatti
con marco ci siamo tanto buttati sulla
sul sull'incontro dal vivo e instagram
ero un po un occhio che spiava troppo
quasi un po esterno cercheremo di
trovare invece in modo proprio di
implementare nelle cose e cercare
cercando di dare anche più importanza e
maggiore possibilità di partecipare a
chi sta magari in un'altra città e se
volete comunque ho detto tutto bene
tutto ma era perfetta the stupendo
vanguarda grazie quindi ragazze grazie
mille veramente di aver preso parte a
questo incontro durante l'estate
l'ultima dobbiamo dire è che
probabilmente a fine lui a fine agosto
non faremo incontri nei live né dal vivo
vabbè lascio perdere neanche il live
così su youtube perché io no magari non
sto a roma per delle cose cui erano
state attivate insomma abbiamo anche noi
le vacanze a un certo punto quindi ci
vediamo con questi incontri a settembre
ci vediamo ogni giorno su instagram su
la chioccia la setta dei libri e nei
ragazzi grazie di aver partecipato
grazie mi ad averci dato la vostra
esperienza e la vostre sensazioni
relazione a questo libro ho studiato
guglielmo finisca di leggerlo si può
dirci la sua magari ve lo farò sapere
perché tanto come come leggevo prima
questo libro rientra anche nel tema poi
apposta quindi dai bene così io
ringrazio ancora cecilia grazie mille
roberta grazie mille annalisa grazie
mille
so che è difficile mettersi in video ma
se state pazzesche sembravate
tranquillissime quindi questo è quello
che roberta fa una marea di storia
mettendoci la faccia ormai è sempre
spetta ma è buono e buoni la prima volta
magari metto un po d'ansia e poi ci si
prende l'abitudine sicuro io mi sentivo
un cretino quando inizia la tetta vale
come corso di public speaking alla fine
ti mandiamo il latte stato grazie
ragazzi
nessun così come immagino che nessuno di
noi giudica nice
nessuno che ci mette la faccia anzi io
apprezzo solamente stimo nessuno lo fa
con noi quindi questa quella cosa
bellissima di questo gruppo è seccato
perché proprio una comunità che secondo
me che voglio sentire tanto in questi
giorni proprio perché ognuno sta
leggendo qualcosa di diverso e del fico
proprio creare un in una missione dicevo
grazie roberta grazie annalisa marco
senza di te non esisteremmo ma lui
tamburi vogliamo fare dinanzi a fini ea
giovanni santo santonocito parametri
prec
qui il nostro sempre mi piace sempre
dirlo il nostro rapolo è venuto l'app il
primo al primo incontro per caso e si è
trovato invischiato ottimo tutti non si
può fare gli auguri però facciamo il e
comunque gli auguri a giovanni che
domani è il suo compleanno non dico
quanti anni compì così figura non avessi
capelli appare assolutamente gli auguri
a giovani domani noi fornirlo dichiaro
poi vero no non mi va di dirlo
il millesimo era mai niente a questo
punto direi ragazzi di salutarci quanti
e di aggiornarci su instagram
scusate di aggiornarci su instagram ok
ciao a tutti ciao ciao grazie a tutti
grazie ciao